[Music]
in
face palm news submitted by danny
california
what's that the song from red house i
knew it i'm not gonna let you ruin my
face you you guessed it before i told
you i guess before you finish the word
a trans oh boy a trans-racial
white couple claims their baby will be
born
black is it that one weird looking lady
oh rachel
dolozies no this one her name is martina
big is that her real name
and you can really be trans racial now
what does that mean
she identifies as black even though she
is white she's from germany
do that i mean you you could say it
doesn't mean you are
be sensitive i can't believe you guys
are so insensitive you have to be
sensitive you don't know what she's been
through
yeah so she's been trying her best to
make it as a model
as a black model well like originally
you know as like a blonde woman
she's one of those that gets like the
big old boobies okay
and so she started taking these
injections
the melanin melanotan
melanotan synthetic hormone
that it's like tanning injection so it
darkens your skin yeah darkens your skin
they are not approved by the fda in the
u.s rightfully so
she received three injections changed
her skin i wonder how fast it changes
and i wonder if it changes some patches
or
all together she also says that it
changed her eye color and it made her
hair grow
incr in curlier and darker she's also
had various surgeries
okay the most racial surgeries ever
i can't even imagine dude she visited
kenya
where she said that she was baptized
with the name
mala malaika kuba
malaika kuba oh that's taika's uh
rhyming name taika malaika
it's swahili for big angel big anus i
thought it was gonna be
a big angel she would not want those
google what does my name mean
i feel like a lot of these like tourist
things they just
play into the tourists that really want
to be like
connected so they could come back and be
like yo i got a kenyan name
yeah so she says that that's where it
completed her transformation into a real
african woman those are her words okay
and then so she went on to this popular
british tv show called this morning
and she showed up with her husband that
she met
another black man that was white exactly
his name is michael oh sure
he's also taking injections and they
also showed up in
toshikis so this is martina
what she used to look like this is what
she looks like now this [ __ ] just lost
her [ __ ] mind
oh lord oh my god what's with the
titties though i don't understand she
has body dysmorphia
yeah yeah look at that go back look at
it he's looking at her titties no his
eyes are closed oh yeah
yeah i like the white curtain
yeah he looks like a jewish guy from new
jersey
she said that a doctor told them that
their kids
will come out mixed like either like
really dark or
light that doctor needs to have his
license revoking he literally said
they're gonna come out like everything
like he said really dark or really like
no like uh oh she looks crazy looking
she looks like a white lady that covered
herself in charcoal have you guys seen
always sunny in philadelphia
when dee she she has a really racist
character that she plays
and that's what she looks like this is
her actual words the baby
it's a mix of michael and me i'm pretty
sure it will be black or milk chocolate
or a little bit light it doesn't matter
this [ __ ] does not know how science
works so is this is this like straight
up stupidity or is it straight up like
a little bit of both for sure she's
deranged but also that this is her hair
i hope they don't have kids they're
black how did they meet
that's [ __ ] crazy internet probably
he probably hit her up but then he saw
her
did she go like oh who's this african
man no he probably told her like i feel
the same way too
i i think it's an internet form white
people that are trapped in like
wait black people that are trapped in
white people's bodies he could have slid
into her dms because i've seen this
woman before
she's gotten some nor notoriety before
and he probably slid into her dms and
told her
i feel the same way he just wanted some
postpartum
it's like the guys that joined hobbies
that like the girl they want to talk to
is
that's that's this guy it's it's uh when
they give birth to a white baby the only
thing i can imagine is that pikachu meme
he's gonna be like you've been cheating
on me oh my god imagine
i hope they don't have kids i wonder how
you can say that you feel like you were
born
a different race because
a lot of the stuff that you feel about
your ethnicity is a social construct
like you grew up with it yeah you grow
up with it's just it's a societal thing
that
molds what you know what i mean yeah so
like culture
is specifically a societal it's a social
construct
so how can you say you're trans racial
like in like
these races don't have a like when
you're born you're born a bran
brand new slate it's not like a race
acts a certain way b
or you know behaves only because it's
born that race you know what i mean so
what does she mean but
i don't understand what trans racial
means what are the attributes that makes
you feel that way aside from skin color
eye color and hair
yeah like the human traits are stuff
that's a social construct right
yeah so i don't understand what that
means that makes no sense
she just thinks she's black what's next
maybe she really likes
black panther trans animals pretend
animals it's gonna be trans animals
there's those people who are like trans
species
have you seen those crazy like um people
that look like cats
they inject or lizards in yeah those
people oh true
they're that's actually kind of cool
trans species makes more sense because
that's completely different different
yeah you know what i mean yeah because
if we're talking about
race i guess that corny is saying
there's only one race to human race
right which in this case it's true so
what what does that mean
that's like if i have a chihuahua and
i'm like you want to meet my great dane
strange and it's funny it's
insane that there's two people that
found each other like this
that guy just like he's never had [ __ ]
before and he was like all right if this
is if i'm finally gonna get [ __ ] you
know what's funny though
the whole when the whole like trans
thing was
like everyone was talking about it and
they're like well if we you know let
people just
identify as like you know male or female
despite what they're like born as then
is going to cause people to like
identify different races and then
they're saying that's a slippery slope
like that can never happen and i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's happening
that's [ __ ] crazy i mean there's
always going to be people that fall
through the cracks
and this is what they were talking about
but this is crazy that it's actually
happening and people were talking about
that [ __ ]
i was like that'll never happen it's
crazy that they're taking steps
towards that too yeah getting injections
and surgeries
which makes me scared like what if they
do have a baby and then they start
giving the baby injections
oh they will i mean oh for sure they
will yeah i remember like
10 years ago or more or longer i
remember
in japan there was like a style that was
going on
yeah there was that the the the kogaru
there was that
tana super tan one super tan one and
then there was another one
where like it was like reggae style so
what they were doing is tanning their
skin and then one was like getting like
dressed
like dreads or like afro style or
whatever and
dressing all like african style or like
jamaican or whatever
but they would not say they're africans
they know they're still japanese but
they just like really living and
breathing that style
they like just the aesthetics of it yeah
they're not like saying i'm a black
woman
don't they have a japanese cholos too
yeah like they'll be
like holding up the mexican yeah they're
holding up the mexican flag
they invite like [ __ ] what's the poco
spell local skies
like you know the all those hispanic rap
artists and then they'll have concerts
and then
all these japanese people holding up
mexican flags and having low riders
you think you're still in east l.a like
they'll do that [ __ ] like that's just
hella trans-racial but
they'll never say outright i'm mexican
i'm a mexican identified as mexican
yeah they're just saying i love mexican
culture i love the low rider style i
love that that's what they're
saying she looks [ __ ] crazy she looks
like a racist drawing of a black person
yeah you know what i mean like back in
the day when they were trying to like
draw like black people that's what she
looks like i like her guy though
if you she's like she just looks like a
[ __ ] witch
you know what this looks like you know
what he could be if you switch his shirt
out with the button up and the hairy
chest and gold chains
he looks like a like one of those
italians in new york yes oh yeah owns
like a sandwich shop or something
kind of like the [ __ ] the sopranos
the james
yeah yeah because he even looked at his
face he's just saying like listen i'm
just doing this i want to kiss him
you know what he also looks like porky
pig too yes
that's all folks he looks like i did not
mean for it to get this far
italian uncle phil dude yeah italian
uncle he looks like he has hairy
knuckles oh for sure hairy feet
no dang dude that's like what is it what
are people saying about i mean i can
imagine they must be getting roasted 100
everyone's like what the [ __ ] and
they're
highly offended of course yeah i would
be too
i'm offended i'm not even black i know i
wouldn't be offended i want people like
this to exist
his name looks like his it would be
paulie i want people to do stupid [ __ ]
cause they are great entertainment
who takes this [ __ ] seriously like the
guy i showed you yeah like people that
are [ __ ] well it kind of looks like
it could be related yeah
i love it dude like i love it when
people think they're
they're like hella japanese like when i
see weebs and [ __ ] like that
i think it's so [ __ ] funny oh chubby
white weebs are the best they are the
best
like why why would you not want that
that shit's
entertaining it's terrifying actually
she looks scary her boobs are painful
dude
oh her boobs are crazy dude painful
don't you guys want
people to make you feel good about life
they don't make me feel good about life
yeah that's why people watch jerry
springer and all these awesome [ __ ]
talk shows i watched jerry springs
[ __ ]
the people's court huh girls titties
came out oh yeah when they fight huh
they don't show up sometimes you blurt
it out but the imagination is crazy like
almost oh sometimes sometimes you see
people like this and you
it it's like i'm a piece of [ __ ] but god
at least i'm not like this yeah
that's why it's so awesome but you have
this yeah
at least i never got that far like
you're special i want to laugh i love
laughing at people's delusions it's the
best
[Music]
bye